sometimes everything goes right
sometimes all the pieces are in the
perfect position your teammates your
opponents all of them are arranged just
right sometimes all the decisions you
make lead up to one perfect moment
sometimes when that moment is just right
you can show the world what it takes to
win six million dollars through a skill
and Trust alone evil geniuses were
considered one of the strongest dota 2
teams in the world heading into the
International thought despite kicking
off the year by losing two of their
strongest players our tour rtz babaev
and ludwig sidewall word nobody wanted
to play with us everyone thought that we
were on the losing end of this Western
shuffle eg still managed to win the dota
2 Asia championships with the help of
Curtis äúi 2008 unproven pub star named
C ed sumail hassan EG went on to play
second at the summit 3 and ESL one
Frankfurt putting them on track to be
one of the favorites heading into TI v
EG finished first in their group and
moved onto the bracket stage with a beat
complexity and people qualifying for the
upper bracket finals but it was there
that EG faced their first true challenge
all tournament c dec gaming went
undefeated in the wild-card stage the
code outs their connect so to the
follow-ups done two more kills accuracy
but a mega kill streak c deck will be in
the main event and placed second in
their group
second only to EG but c dec beat both
cloud nine and LGD gaming 202 make it to
the winners finals where they trounced
eg 2-0 we kind of thought we knew how to
play against them and we kind of thought
we could handle their playstyle but we
were totally wrong everything just
started going wrong for us like we
overestimated like
and we underestimated them and they just
completely destroyed us in that beste -
is a very fast to zero
eg dropped down to the lower bracket and
beat LGD - OH
to earn another shop that see it easy eg
took Game one but see Dec fought back
taking game - and keeping it close
[Applause]
rallied in Game three but Game four was
where Ichi made magic happen
going back in to face selecting the
grand finals it was really useful that
we lost to them in the winners finals
just because we were able to sort of
predict what they wanted to do in the
games who want to like invade our jungle
we knew what they were banned we know
that they were strong with luck we had a
lucky points of information that we
could use throughout the series
eg targeted aggressive forcing him to
play his weaker heroes it puddi G at an
advantage through most of the series
they didn't take Naga they didn't they
took first big as well I predicted but
I'm very surprised with this me I think
this threw them off a lot because they
expected us to first pick not a siren
because that's one of our best heroes
and they thought they were gonna get
gyrocopter for aggressive but because we
knew that we they didn't play Naga we
had no reason to prioritize it when
gyrocopter is just like such a deny pick
from from them see Dec was forced to let
sumail back on his signature storm
spirit telephone specially at this level
of super
can't be stressed enough as the still um
you've predicted and to prevent him from
wreaking havoc they tried to focus him
and they'll use the curse with Lacuna
fight Sammael the concert on a piece for
also saw the ring of Aquila and some
males blink dragon tail stun God is
gonna be here with the option as well
the good appliance amount the calls
wound the coax bird vaulted a little bit
of extra time and with some mail down a
note by back brush on is a very very
juicy target here for CDC was sumail
down C Dec was desperate so they needed
to move fast they rushed for Roshan
hoping they could win the ensuing fight
for v5 I don't think if you're
interested in contesting this warrant
fire but maybe they get to lay it long
enough it's via five on five if they ice
blast and Fisher properly there is no
hook shot they're all together
PPG he comes the ice blasts or any good
[Applause]
you see Dec so grouped up PPD and
universe's combo utterly shredded their
health bars effectively winning the game
then in there
eg couldn't see all the see Dec
independent in fact universe was
effectively going in blind
but he trusted his intuition he trusted
his team we didn't have vision of them
at the time but then I told PPE to throw
in a nice vortex and he threw it in
there and I saw a couple of them so I
just assumed they'd all be in there and
I just made a blind leap of faith and
then they were they're all in there and
they all died an echo slam hits every
enemy around the Earthshaker which means
teams tend to avoid grouping up against
him but either out of desperation or
confidence see Dec were in the perfect
position for the biggest echo slam in
dota history
and I just yelled I don't even know what
talking about of my mouth but it was
pretty loud it wasn't just a huge play
it was a championship winning play its
single-handedly won eg the tournament
and finally gave na dota some
recognition eg hasn't quite been the
same team since day one TI but the echo
slam lives on as one of the biggest
plays in dota 2 history it lives on as a
reminder that trust and teamwork can
always win a championship
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]